allez dans quelques instants va me
rejoindre le plateau du 7-8 sofival on
va parler des initiatives écologiques au
sein du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse mais avant
cela sophie a rencontré cdp chat il est
fondateur du psycho ou comment le marc
de café peut servir d'engrais pour les
champignons
nous sommes dans une ferme un peu
spéciale à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse
série de pêcheurs cultive depuis six
mois des champignons des pleurotes de
manière écologique que vous allez
comprendre comment
cédric pescia bonjour merci nous de
recevoir dans une goutte est maire alors
pourquoi un container d'abord alors
faites ceci c'est une unité de
production agricole autonome donc le
container on soit c'est un module qu'on
va pouvoir transporter et il ya un mois
il était encore au milieu de paris est
là maintenant il est ici dans un site
complètement agricole donc il y avait
une logique est le mal installés ici
est-ce que vous produisez donc ici ce
sont des pleurotes y en a pleins partout
à différents stades oui donc là on voit
différents stades effectivement de
maturation là des jeunes des jeunes
pousses
ici elles ont à peu près une semaine et
dans deux jours seront prêtes à être
récoltées combien vous en produisez vous
par mois par semaine alors un container
produit 15 kilos par jour de pleurotes
toute l'année quelle que soit la météo
externe mais si on en met 10 à côté mais
on a tout de suite en gros volumes de
production ce qui est l'intérêt des prix
des conteneurs c'est d'être très
modulaire très modulable dans le dans la
production
si votre entreprise est qualifiée d'
écologique c'est pour une raison alors
effectivement en fait à la base c'est
pas un projet uniquement de production
de champignons c'est un projet de
montage d'une filière de collecte de
marc de café donc c'est une filière de
collecte régional sur l'île de france et
on va transformer ce marc de café qui
est pasteurisé par les distributeurs de
café les machines automatiques en fait
pasteurisé le café et font de la
collecte de ce marc de café et vous ce
marc de café vous l'utilisez voilà donc
on récupère comme substrat course et
cette production de champignons c'est
beau le marc de café pour les plantes
c'est excellent c'est excellent ça nous
permet d'avoir un produit beaucoup plus
charnue beaucoup qui a beaucoup moins
d'eau beaucoup plus de goût et une
texture que les restaurateurs apprécie
énormément ce marc de café il n'est pas
utilisé brut même s'il est pasteurisé
alors quasiment c'est
toute la difficulté a été membre de
monter une filière assez fluide pour ne
pas avoir à transformer ce mardi passé
donc le marc de café cayla il a moins
d'une semaine en moyenne donc il n'est
pas du tout moisi il est complètement
frais et on utilise directement donc on
lancement savez du mycélium de
champignons on rajoute un peu de copeaux
de bois pour lui pour l'aérer et c'est
tout il ya aucune autre transformation
n'y a pas de produits chimiques y a pas
de traitement thermique c'est une
utilisation en flux continu j'ai vu que
vous aviez un autre container où on voit
les différentes étapes du marc de café
on peut y aller peut-être
alors où est ce qu'on se trouve ici
alors là on se trouve dans une autre
partie du système qui s'appelle
l'incubateur dans cet incubateur on va
produire des salles de substrat qui sont
constitués à 90% de marc de café et qui
petit à petit vont être envahis de
mycélium de champignons ou en blanc à
cesser les tâches qu'on voit en blanc
commence à se développer pour au bout
d'un mois être complètement
pour au bout d'un mois complètement
recouvrir la surface et l'intérieur du
sac peut en faire une bûche
une bûche très très dense et à partir de
ce set là on peut produire des
champignons en changeant totalement
toutes les conditions de température
d'humidité de co2 de ventilation
inscrits dans cette unité on a des
capteurs qui gère que ces paramètres là
pour pouvoir gérer à la demande des
différentes phases de maturité de des
champignons de façon classique comment
on fait on n'utilise pas du marc de café
qu'est-ce que ça de façon classique les
producteurs de schubert ne produisent
plus leur substrat on est seul en france
à faire ça on est quelques uns dans le
monde d'habitude les champignons comme
des pleurotes pousse sur de la paille
qui est pasteurisé par des gros acteurs
de l'e du marché du substrat donc là on
est vraiment très très
particulier par rapport au monde du
champignon en général quel est votre
objectif l'objectif c'est de montrer
qu'on peut faire des partenariats entre
des start up innovantes le monde dans
l'insertion autour d'un modèle
économique écologique et social où
finalement tout le monde va trouver un
rôle à jouer donc c'est vraiment un
nouveau modèle économique est donc
l'objectif est ensuite c'est de
dupliquer tout cet ensemble là dans
d'autres c'est à tes et d'autres lieux
pourquoi pas un jour imaginé de produire
au milieu de rungis à partir de
containers des champignons qui seront
vendus sur place pour le pour les
marchés parisiens à rungis où pour
l'instant on peut trouver jo pleurotes
alors effectivement pour l'instant toute
la production est vendue à rungis donc
on a déjà le circuit commercial il
manque plus que se rapprocher encore
plus du circuit de distribution
produisant au milieu d'un circuit de
distribution ce qui est là la vraie
valeur ajoutée d'un système comme ça
modulaire abaisse de compte merci
beaucoup d'emprise
bon allez on revient sans pato du 7-8
sophie vous n'êtes pas venus avec des
pleurotes non je vais laisser la barre
et vise à vous un peu cher mais savoir à
l'abri tous les d'importantes un produit
rapidement une initiative qui donc
revalorise les déchets et qui a été
primé par le parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse c'est pour ça
que vous êtes là xavier stefan bonjour
bonjour donc vous êtes chargé d'études
développement économique dans ce parc
est ce que vous pouvez peut-être
m'expliquer le prix qu'il a eu c'est le
grand prix du jury c'est le meilleur
prix un des meilleurs prix oui tout à
fait en fait on a des catégories
classiques en fait agriculteurs
collectivités associations et ensuite on
a
attribué fin des élus ont attribué en
fait un grand prix à des projets qu'il
trouve exceptionnel innovants et donc
qu'ils ont voulu vraiment mettre en
avant donc celui-là a été un peu le coup
de coeur celui-là il était fait partie
des deux coups de coeur voilà avec les
éco actions les isa qui sont à saint
jean de beauregard pour le recyclage de
batx et pourquoi le coup de coeur parce
que parce que c'est un projet très
innovant et qui a intègre en fait le
recyclage de matières de la base jusqu'à
comme le substrat que vous n'êtes pas eu
le temps d'aborder même le substrat une
fois qu'il a produite et des champignons
peuvent elles servir comme amendement
agricoles pour des agriculteurs dont il
a bouclé
qu'est ce que c'est vos écoutes défi
vous écouterez au fait qu'est ce que ça
veut dire exactement alors en fête au
parc on a trois dispositifs de
valorisation des démarches
environnementales des entreprises de
management environnemental
on a par ordre de priorité par deux
d'importance on à la marque par qui est
une marque qui appartient à l'état qui
est déposé à l'inpi et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire cette marque par les marées la
marque parc c'est en fait une un
lasso de reconnaissance qui est attribué
à des professionnels qui s'engagent à
travers un cahier des charges d'une
trentaine de points bien déterminé et
voilà qu'ils sont labellisés donc du
coup par par le parc naturel qui vont
donc faire des efforts environnementaux
c'est ça faire les efforts les ya trois
critères en fait trois grands domaines
dans la mare qui a le territoire donc le
fait que tout soit produit sur place
l'environnement c'est à dire qu'il ya un
respect de l'environnement des pratiques
raisonnées qui sont exigés et ensuite il
y a la dimension humaine c'est-à-dire la
volonté de transmettre son savoir à des
programmes à des particuliers des
consommateurs donc en gros vous primes
et des acteurs économiques qui sont
locaux pas très loin de chez nous et qui
font des efforts comme ça
environnementaux tout à fait alors
aujourd'hui on a trente quatre
professionnels sur la marque park qui
représente
93 emplois précisément et un chiffre
d'affaires de 4 7 millions d'euros donc
c'est aussi un dispositif très important
soixante candidats cette année 60
candidats sur écoute trophées eco défi
donc ensuite ce sont les deux autres
dispositifs de management
environnemental que l'on gère dans
quelques trophées le principe c'est un
projet lauréat un projet exemplaire et
innovant lauréats dans cette catégorie
il a par exemple le projet qu'on a vu
voilà tout à fait les dons qu'il y en a
eu six autres noms des cars 2 grand prix
du jury et quatre lauréats dans des
catégories classiques
voire parler et puis échos défis alors
écho défi le principe est assez simple
est ce vraiment pour permettre à tout le
monde d'accéder en fait à la au concours
c'est il faut il ya une mise au défi qui
sont proposés dans les domaines de lait
ou de l'eau de l'énergie de retraitement
des déchets et ainsi de suite et il faut
faire trois défis pour participer
simplement à l'opération puis on en fait
plus on est
labellisé puis on est reconnu en fait à
travers ce concours c'est quoi
l'objectif de ce concours de ces
concours différents là les objectifs en
fait pour le parc c'est d'inciter les
professionnels à mettre en avant et
politiques environnementales
et ensuite d'avoir des outils de de
labellisation de mise en avant
pour que les encourager à poursuivre
alors donc on l'a dit à beaucoup
d'autres projets beaucoup de catégories
différentes jeu j'ai vu par exemple
qu'il y à une catégorie de commerçants
et artisans en écho défi un supermarché
bio qui a été primé est-ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer un petit peu pourquoi
on à belize comme ça on met en avant un
supermarché bio là on le voit si on la
liste alors là la menthe poivrée
effectivement participé à l'opération
pourquoi et comment alors du coup ils
ont réalisé 12 13 défi donc dans ses
traits ce défi il veut dire par exemple
ça peut être tout simplement voilà la
mise en place d'un luminaire économes en
énergie en masse en sicile et ça c'est
assez facile effectivement
donc il ya un certain nombre d'actions
comme la mise en place de robinets
mitigeurs qui est sont là qui permet de
faire des économies d'échelle figure
quand même yann labrit physionomie
de me diriger la même chose chez moi
mais vous n'êtes pas de supermarché bio
marché alors effectivement
déjà c'est une démarche globale donc ça
veut dire que sur un certain nombre de
défis qui sont parmi ceux là assez
facile ils ont réalisé 13 donc de
manière générale sont vraiment impliqués
dans la démarche et puis il ya quand
même un défi qui est ressorti un petit
peu parmi la liste plus jeune vous citer
ces défis de sensibilisation de la
clientèle à l'environnement c'est à dire
que supermarché c'est peu commun
organise des des ciné-débats organise
des conférences organise des pétitions
et donc voilà pour cet effort aussi été
primé parmi le meilleur prix de cette
catégorie c'est à dire un écho défi de
platine si vous deviez citer un ou deux
projets qui vous ont marqués vraiment
cette année parce que ça existe donc
depuis 2005 ce concours globalement
qu'est ce qui a aidé vous à petit ce qui
vous a marqué cette année alors sur les
échos défi on a trois projets qui sont
assez intéressants la ferme des trois
ponts par exemple à vieille-église a mis
en place en fait un système de panneaux
solaires sur 250 mètres carrés de
surface ce qui représente à peu près 40
1000 kilowatts heure par an produits en
termes d'énergie soit la moitié de sa
consommation annuelle
donc là c'est intéressant ensuite on a
eu également la teinturerie pagès qui a
mis en place un produit non alors là
c'est juste les échos défi ok tu as tu
ris pagès donc a mis en place un produit
à base de 100% de détergents naturels à
base de grosses lunettes naturel pour
remplacer le perchloroéthylène il est un
polluant donc voilà pour les échos des
filets de projets les plus intéressants
et ensuite sur les autres catégories
donc on à l'école de courson monteloup
qu'une petite école de 66 ans habitant
qui a mis en place un hub à et pour
construire en fait son école et qui a
mis en place un système de chauffage par
géothermie à tous puis en géothermiques
sont réalisés car pour son image in pour
la langue pour nous en tout cas à notre
connaissance c'est le meilleur bâtiments
publics un point de vue énergétique dans
le parc naturel et en plus donc le
concours vise aussi à primer l'effort
consenti par les les porteurs de projet
pour mettre en place cet investissement
mettre en place le projet donc pour une
commune de 600 habitants c'est
merci beaucoup à tout ces informations
voilà je vous donne un petit peu des
dates aussi à retenir trois dates à
retenir effectivement cette semaine à
commencer par demain le 26 juin un
atelier communication animale pour
découvrir la bio acoustique et se mettre
dans la peau d'un chercheur samedi nous
allions
chercheurs le bio acousticien vacant
samedi 29 juin vous pourrez foncé au
concert poétique aux écolos rock tout un
programme c'est l'histoire d'une graine
qui rêve de devenir un arbre majestueux
et c'est par la compagnie terry qui est
campagne
et puis le même jour découvrez l'étang
de la base de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines en balade à vélo vous
comprendrez pourquoi louis xiv à
commander et son aménagement voilà merci
sophy par la chronique en environnement
merci à vous d'être venu en plateau